hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to the Tim Ferriss
show this episode is an exciting one and
I will start with a quote the quote is
from Robert Frost it is freedom lies and
being bold if anything our guest this
episode is about being bold his name is
Peter teal and he is a serial tech
founder PayPal Palantir billionaire
investor and author of the new book zero
to one I'll come back to all of those
things but whether you want to be a
better investor I've certainly modelled
Peter and have him to thank I think for
many of my best decisions in the world
of investing a better entrepreneur or
simply a free thinker who wants to do
great things create more value I highly
recommend not only this interview but
certainly that you read zero to one
which is a collection of many of his
teachings on differentiation value
creation competition it is a treasure
trove now Peter who is Peter and if
you're not familiar with him I'll give
you a quick snapshot he co-founded in
1998 PayPal that was the beginning which
was sold to eBay in 2002 for 1.5 billion
dollars but more notable I think is the
team that he helped to assemble and
these individuals known now as the
PayPal mafia that's what they're
referred to as when I'm to launch a raft
of companies that have become household
names including at least seven now
valued at more than 1 billion dollars I
mean literally almost every single
person on the founding team if not every
person has gone on to create
multibillion-dollar company so you have
Tesla and SpaceX co-founded by Elon Musk
LinkedIn of course Reed Hoffman YouTube
Steve Chen Chad Hurley
Javad Yelp Jeremy Stoppelman Russell
Simmons Yammer David Sachs and the data
mining company Palantir which teal
himself co-founded in 2004 he was also
the first outside investor in facebook
and has invested in more than 100
startups he has done a lot he has
learned a lot and perhaps most important
he consistently questions assumptions
and thinks differently so I don't want
to delay this any further but I will say
this interview was an experiment
I was on sick leave so we did it a
synchronously what you will hear is
blake masters who is a co-author on 0 to
1 reading the questions peter answering
them because i was unable to be there in
person although I have met Peter on a
few occasions before there are also
written questions and answers and you
can find those written questions and
answers on the blog go to 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcast
click on this episode and it'll take you
to the right place so without further
ado I hope you enjoy this interview
please share your thoughts on twitter at
t-- ferrous that is made to ours two S's
or on facebook at slash tim ferriss two
hours two S's and thank you so much for
listening at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking no I also
posted a question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton blue this is a
Peter teal I'm happy to be here on the
Tim Ferriss show thank you for having me
since Tim is out my co-author Blake
masters is the voice you hear asking
questions that came from Tim and his
audience let's get started what do you
believe that very few others do well for
starters I think this is a much harder
question to answer than it sounds
I give a number of different answers in
my in my book one high level answer is
that I think technology is far more
important in our world than
globalization even though we're in a
world where people are very focused on
globalization on copying things that
work and much less on technology on
doing new things and I think and we need
to shift that hierarchy around and we
need to see technology as the main
driver for progress in the 21st century
a second answer that I that I come to on
the business side that I think is quite
contrarian is that whereas most people
believe that capitalism and competition
are synonyms I think they are antonyms
a capitalist to someone who's in the
business of accumulating capital in a
world of perfect competition all the
capital is competed away and so for
example the restaurant industry in San
Francisco is incredibly competitive but
not very capitalistic because no one
ever makes any money at it whereas
Google is a very capitalistic company
which has made enormous profits for the
last dozen years but has had no real
competition ever since it's definitively
distanced itself from Yahoo and
Microsoft around 2002 what do you wish
you had known about business 20 years
ago if you go back 20 25 years I wish I
would have known that there was no need
to wait I went to college I went to law
school I worked in law and and banking
though not for terribly long but not
until I really started PayPal did I
fully realize that you don't have to
wait to start something so if you're if
you're planning to do something with
your life if you have a 10-year plan of
how to get there you should ask why
can't you do this in six months
sometimes you have to actually go
through the 10 year complex 10 year
trajectory but it's at least worth
asking with that's just a story you're
telling yourself or whether that's the
reality
how important is failure in business
well I think failure is massively
overrated most businesses fail for more
than one reason and so when a business
fails you often don't learn anything at
all because the failure was over
determined you will think it failed for
reason number one but it failed for
reasons numbers one through five and so
the next business you start will fail
for reason number two and then for three
and so on and so I think people actually
do not learn very much from failure and
I think it ends up being quite damaging
and demoralizing to people in the long
run my sense is that the death of every
business is a tragedy it's not some sort
of beautiful aesthetic where there's a
lot of carnage but that's how progress
happens and it's not some sort of
educational imperative so I think
failure is neither a Darwinian nor an
educational imperative failure is always
simply a tragedy when you hear the word
successful who's the first person you
think of and why Mark Zuckerberg the why
seemed silly he's done tremendously well
or someone like Elon Musk we've had a
serial entrepreneurs created multiple
mega billion-dollar companies in the
last in the last few decades what I
think people like Zuckerberg or mosques
court Jeff Bezos at Amazon have in
common is that they're relentless
they don't stop every day they start
over do more and get better at it
people often ask whether Facebook was
just a fluke in the right place at the
right time but I think the more you get
to know Marc or founders like him the
less plausible it becomes and that's in
part because you can see how hard works
how much planning there was how much of
a vision there was from the very
beginning where do you see Bitcoin going
or not going in the future
bitcoin is a class struggle with many of
the same issues PayPal encountered when
we started in the late 90s we to try to
create a new
currency and we started by creating a
new payment system paypal worked by
linking money and e-mail and became very
powerful on that on that score although
it never quite achieved its a goal of
creating a completely new currency i
think bitcoin in some ways is the
opposite configuration of paypal it has
succeeded in creating a new currency but
perhaps not yet a new payment system and
so people are speculating in bitcoin as
a store of value but they're not yet
using bitcoin that extensively to
transact for bitcoin to really succeed i
think it will have to be not just a
currency but also a payment system what
are the biggest tech trends that you see
defining the future
I don't like talking in terms of tech
trends because I think once you have a
trend you have many people doing it and
once you have many people doing
something you have lots of competition
and little differentiation you generally
never want to be part of a popular trend
you do not want to be the fourth online
pet food company in the late 90s you did
not want to be the 12th thin panel solar
company in the last decade and you don't
want to be the end of the company of any
particular trend so I think trends are
often things to to avoid what I prefer
over trends is a sense of mission that
you're working on a unique problem that
people are not solving elsewhere when
Elon Musk started SpaceX they set out
the mission to go to Mars you may agree
or disagree with that as a mission
statement but it was a problem that was
not going to be solved outside of SpaceX
and all the people working there knew
that and it motivated them tremendously
so I think unique missions are much to
be preferred over trends it is because
every moment and technology happens only
once and it's always a unique
constellation of technologies and people
and the world where where the time is
right right now for a new kind of thing
to come about why do so many investors
spray-and-pray
instead of focusing on just five to
seven companies and each fund like you
do it founders fund and the second part
of the question do you have any any
rules that you follow or tips for those
who want to invest in early-stage
ventures more intelligently I think
people would say that they
spray-and-pray because of some sort of
portfolio theory some sort of
diversification theory and if that's
true
that might work I don't actually believe
that to be true I think the real reason
people a spray-and-pray and they're
investing is that they are lacking in
any conviction and perhaps because
they're too lazy to really spend the
time to try to figure out what companies
are ultimately going to work one of the
reasons I do not like that sort of
approach to investing is that I don't
think it's good to treat companies as
lottery tickets
it's terrible to treat the founders of
companies as lottery tickets and I think
it's actually not just sort of a bad
thing morally to treat people as lauder
chicks I also think it's really bad as
an investor as an investor you know once
you say that there's a small probability
of a big payoff small number times big
number
normally equals a small number and so
once you are thinking in lottery ticket
terms you've already psyched yourself
into writing checks without thinking and
therefore losing money and and so I
think that the anti lottery ticket
approach is to try to be concentrated
because that forces you to have high
levels of conviction before you write a
check of any size and then I think
you'll do much better what problem do
you face every day that nobody has
solved yet well the problem that I
remain the most passionate about is is
for us to make some real and continued
progress in the fight against aging and
death this is not just about my face as
a problem you know everybody on this
planet faces we have about a hundred
thousand people a day who die mostly
from diseases linked to old age and so I
always find extraordinary is how little
we're doing about this problem it seems
that people are either in a mode of
denial or acceptance which are in some
ways opposite extremes but they both
have the effect of stopping you from
doing anything if you are in denial and
say this is not a problem where you
accept it and say there's nothing you
can do about it
both of these are sort of passive modes
and what I think we need is a much more
active mode instead of being in denial
or acceptance I would like us to
spending a lot more time of fighting
death there people who say that death is
natural and to which I think the
response always has to be that there is
nothing more natural for us than to
fight death what would you say to the
nine point seven million unemployed
people in America let me give both a
micro and a macro answer to this on a
micro answer I think I don't think
there's any sort of one-size-fits-all
approach I think there are very
different kinds of facts and
circumstances in which people find
themselves in and I think that a reason
approach you know would involve you know
very careful looking at why people are
there are they in a long-term unemployed
situation where they were working a Rust
Belt factory with a job that no longer
exists or are they a twenty-something
college student who studied a major that
was poorly advised miss founded as
accumulated a mountain of debt and so I
think I think we always always want to
approach this was with far more
granularity and that there's no sort of
one-size-fits-all approach the macro
answer though that I think is is
critical is that we need to find a way
for there to be just more growth in our
overall economy if the US economy was
growing at a rate of four percent a year
I think these problems would broadly get
solved and the challenge has been that
we've been having growth of one or two
percent for the last seven eight years
and that sort of growth rate is not
enough to overcome structural
unemployment it's my view that
technology is the key driver for growth
especially in developed nation like the
US and therefore anything we can do to
accelerate technological progress and
technological innovation will increase
growth and ultimately will increase
opportunities for people throughout our
society how would you reply to someone
who says that your position on college
and higher education is hypocritical
since you yourself went to Stanford for
both undergraduate and law school well
you know I think some people will always
find objections of one sort or another
had I not gone to stand for law school
people would object and say that I had
no idea what I was missing so I think
they're they're likely to complain in
any event but I would say my view is not
hypocritical because I've never made the
claim that there's a one-size-fits-all
so if I said that nobody should go to
college that might be hypocritical but I
what I have said is that not everybody
should do the same thing and and that
there is something very odd about a
society where the most talented people
all get tracked towards the same elite
colleges where they end up studying the
same small number of subjects and going
the same small number of careers and
that strike
me as sort of a lack of diversity are
thinking about the kinds of things
people should be doing that's very
limiting for our society as well as for
those students I certainly think I was
guilty of very much of this myself if I
look back on my Stanford undergraduate
and lost school years it's possible I
would do it do it again but if I had to
do something over I would think about it
much harder I would ask questions why am
I doing this am i doing this just
because I have good grades and test
scores and because I think it's
prestigious or am I doing this because
I'm extremely passionate about
practicing law so I think they're good
answers and they're bad answers and my
sort of retrospective on my my early 20s
is that I was a way too focused on the
wrong answers at the time you studied
philosophy as an undergraduate what is
philosophy have to do with business and
and how is your study of philosophy
helped you and you're investing in
career today I'm not sure how much the
formal study of philosophy matters but I
think the fundamental philosophical
question is one that's important for all
of us and it's always this question of
what do people agree merely by
convention and what is the truth and
this is always the fundamental
distinction in a society is there's a
consensus of things that people believe
to be true and maybe the conventions are
right and maybe they're not and we never
want to let a convention be a shortcut
for truth we always need to ask is this
true this is always where I get at with
this indirect question tell me something
that's true that very few people agree
with you on Silicon Valley is a place
that is laden with conventional thinking
and and one of the reasons that it may
afflict Silicon Valley even more than
the rest of our society is that there
are so few markers you know one of the
things we're focused on Silicon Valley
is the future and the future is not
always a clear thing people can be
uncertain about it and when they're
uncertain about the future they will try
to find shortcuts involved looking at
what other people say about the future
and when everybody simply is listening
to everybody else that's the definition
of a bubble or of a mass psychosocial
insanity and so I think this this
question of trying to think for yourself
trying to break through convention is uh
is always important but perhaps even
more in Silicon Valley than most places
what do you think the future of
education looks like I don't like the
word education because it is such an
extraordinary abstraction I'm very much
in favor of learning I am much more
skeptical of credentialing or the
abstraction called education and so
there's they're all these granular
questions like what is it that you are
learning why are you learning it are you
going to call us because the four-year
party is it a consumption decision is it
an investment decision where you're
investing your future is it insurance or
is it a tournament where you're just
beating other people and our elite
universities really like studio 54 where
it's like a exclusive nightclub I think
if we move beyond the education bubble
that we're living in today the future
will be one which people can speak about
these things more clearly and we will
talk about is it an investment decision
is it a tournament is it a trade or
vocational skill that you're developing
I think engineering is the opposite of
education because it is actually a
specific skill that people are learning
and it's sort of engineering as a
discipline cuts the most against the
banality that we're always told that
you're just learning how to learn or
you're not learning anything in
particular you don't know why you're
learning things engineering is sort of
the anti education in that sense and I
think is in some ways a paradigm for the
way I think it will be more in the
future
I think we will have much less of a
one-size-fits-all approach I think the
big tract institutions are delivering
less and less and charging more and more
and so I think we are sort of at a point
where where things will look very
different one of my friends suggested
that we are at a point education that's
like the place where the Catholic Church
was on the eve of the Reformation it
comes through a very corrupt institution
it was charging more and more for
indulgences people thought they could
only get saved by going to Catholic
Church just like people today believe
that salvation involves getting a
college to
Roma and if you don't get a college
diploma that you're gonna go to hell I
think my answer is in some ways like
that of the Reformers in the sixteenth
century it is the same disturbing answer
that you don't have to figure out your
salvation on your own
what are your daily habits and routines
always feel I'm a terrible person
answering that question uh since things
are very unstructured on many ways but
I'd say one thing that I try to do every
day is to have a conversation with some
of the smartest people I know and
continue to develop my thinking so I'm
trying to learn new things I find that I
learned them from other people and it's
it's often people with whom I've had
conversations for a long time so it's
not an MTV approach where you talk to a
new smart person every day it's one
where you have sustained conversations
with a group of friends or people who've
been working with for a long time and
you come back to thinking about some of
some of these questions and that's how
that's how I find I really continue to
learn everyday and expand my thinking
about the world what one thing would you
most like to change about yourself or
improve on it's always hard to answer
this since uh it sort of begs the
question of why I haven't already
improved on it but I would say that when
I look back on on my younger self I was
I was insanely tracked insanely
competitive and when you're very
competitive you get good at the thing
you were competing with people on but it
comes at the expense of losing out on
many other things so if you're a
competitive chess player you might get
very good at chess but neglect to
develop other things because you're
focused on beating your competitors
rather than on on doing something that's
important or valuable and so I become I
think much more self-aware over the
years about the problematic nature of a
lot of the competitions and rivalries
that we get caught up in and I would not
pretend to have extricated myself in
this altogether so I think every day
it's something to reflect on and think
about how do I become less competitive
in order that I can become more
successful what did you want to achieve
by writing zero to one when you write a
book like this you
Kynan reaches broaden audience as
possible there's there's much that I've
learned in the last 15 years as a as
both a entrepreneur and investor in the
technology industry and I wanted to
share some of these lessons not just at
Stanford but also in Silicon Valley and
with with the wider world I think this
question of technology is critical to
our society and building a better future
in the 21st century and I think there's
both sort of a alarmist and a hopeful
part of this book the the alarmist part
is that if we do not get our act
together and innovate more we will have
a bleak in stagnant century ahead of us
and on the other hand the positive side
is that there's absolutely nothing about
all the great ideas have been found it's
not the case that all the low-hanging
fruit has been picked there's a great
deal of things that can be done that
people can achieve there are many great
secrets left to be unlocked in the
decades ahead and so so I think it is
primarily a cultural question of what we
need to do to get back to the future
most business books take a 30 page essay
and expand into 300 pages of writing and
I tried to do the opposite with zero to
one I tried to take everything I've
learned in the last 15 years and distill
it into 200 discipline pages so that you
can read it in one afternoon writing
this book helped me organize and advance
my thinking tremendously and I hope it
does the same for its readers
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog comm f where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more follow tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or on facebook at
facebook.com slash Tim Ferriss til next
time thanks for listening
you